witaj ponownie w kursie „Rozumienie kwantowej informacji i obliczeń", nazywam się John Watrous i jestem technicznym
dyrektorem ds. edukacji w IBM Quantum. To jest 11. lekcja serii i trzecia lekcja w
trzeciej jednostce, która dotyczy ogólnego sformułowania informacji kwantowej. Ta lekcja jest o pomiarach, które stanowią
interfejs między informacją kwantową a klasyczną. Gdy pomiar jest wykonywany na układzie znajdującym się w
stanie kwantowym, wyodrębniana jest informacja klasyczna, ujawniająca coś o tym stanie kwantowym i zazwyczaj zmieniająca lub
niszcząca ten stan w trakcie. W uproszczonym sformułowaniu informacji kwantowej, które zostało omówione
w pierwszej jednostce serii, zazwyczaj ograniczamy uwagę do pomiarów rzutowych, w tym do
najprostszego rodzaju pomiarów — pomiarów w bazie standardowej. Możliwe jest jednak uogólnienie pojęcia pomiaru
i okazuje się, że jest to całkiem przydatne. W tej lekcji omówimy pomiary w pełnej ogólności,
w tym jak są opisywane w terminach matematycznych i jak wpisują się w ogólne sformułowanie
informacji kwantowej. Pod koniec lekcji przyjrzymy się też kilku fundamentalnym pojęciom związanym z pomiarami, mianowicie rozróżnianiu stanów kwantowych
i tomografii stanów kwantowych. Zaczynajmy — oto przegląd
lekcji. Jak często robimy, zaczniemy od podstaw, w tym od kilku różnych, ale równoważnych sposobów
opisywania pomiarów w terminach matematycznych. W szczególności możemy opisywać pomiary przez kolekcje macierzy
i możemy je też opisywać jako kanały, o czym wspominałem w poprzedniej lekcji. Omówimy też pomiary częściowe,
czyli innymi słowy pomiary wykonywane tylko na jednej części większego złożonego
układu. Następnie przejdziemy do twierdzenia Neumark'a, które jest fundamentalnym faktem dotyczącym pomiarów, mówiącym w skrócie, że ogólne pomiary można zawsze zaimplementować w prosty sposób przypominający reprezentacje Stein-spring
kanałów. Krótko mówiąc, ogólne pomiary można zawsze zaimplementować, najpierw wprowadzając
zainicjalizowany system workspace, następnie wykonując operację unitarną i na koniec wykonując pomiar w bazie standardowej
na systemie workspace. Okazuje się, że jest to dość łatwe do udowodnienia i zobaczymy, jak to działa,
a także jak łączy się to z tzw. pomiarami niedestrukcyjnymi, które opiszę. Wreszcie w ostatniej części
lekcji omówimy rozróżnianie stanów kwantowych i tomografię stanów kwantowych. Zaczniemy od matematycznych
opisów pomiarów. Pomiary zapewniają nam interfejs między informacją kwantową a
klasyczną. Gdy pomiar jest wykonywany na układzie znajdującym się w pewnym stanie kwantowym, wyodrębniana jest klasyczna informacja
o tym stanie kwantowym. Ponadto stan kwantowy jest zazwyczaj zmieniany lub ewentualnie
całkowicie niszczony. Początkowo skupimy uwagę na tzw. pomiarach destrukcyjnych, gdzie
stan kwantowy wchodzi, a wychodzi tylko informacja klasyczna, więc nie ma specyfikacji
stanu kwantowego po pomiarze układu, który był mierzony. Intuicyjnie możemy sobie wyobrazić, że pomiar destrukcyjny
niszczy jakikolwiek układ, który był mierzony, więc jego stan po przeprowadzeniu pomiaru nie jest
określony. Nie oznacza to dosłownie, że fizyczne urządzenia są koniecznie niszczone — to tylko opis matematyczny
i jest on bardzo przydatny, bo pomaga zachować prostotę i skupić się na zasadniczych
aspektach matematycznych pomiarów. Istnieją w szczególności dwa równoważne sposoby opisywania destrukcyjnych
pomiarów, o których wspominałem podczas przeglądu lekcji. Jednym sposobem opisania destrukcyjnego
pomiaru jest kolekcja macierzy, gdzie w szczególności mamy jedną macierz dla każdego możliwego wyniku pomiaru.
Drugim sposobem opisania destrukcyjnego pomiaru jest kanał, gdzie
wejściem jest stan jakiegokolwiek układu, który jest mierzony, a wyjściem jest zawsze diagonalna macierz gęstości, którą możemy
interpretować jako opis rozkładu prawdopodobieństwa po możliwych klasycznych wynikach pomiaru.
Oba opisy są równoważne i jest to całkiem przydatne, bo pozwala nam wybrać ten opis, który jest wygodniejszy w danej
sytuacji. Omówimy też pomiary niedestrukcyjne, gdzie oprócz klasycznego wyniku pomiaru
określony jest też stan kwantowy po pomiarze układu, który był mierzony.
Pomiary niedestrukcyjne są ważne i pojawiają się często, ale w pewnym sensie są
jakoś mniej fundamentalne niż pomiary destrukcyjne — przynajmniej w terminach matematycznych. W szczególności okazuje się,
że pomiary niedestrukcyjne można zawsze opisywać jako złożenia kanałów i pomiarów destrukcyjnych, i
zobaczymy, jak to działa nieco później w lekcji. Przyjrzyjmy się teraz, jak pomiary, czyli pomiary destrukcyjne,
można opisywać jako kolekcje macierzy. W tej dyskusji będziemy zakładać, że X to układ, który jest
mierzony, i dla uproszczenia przyjmiemy kilka założeń. Po pierwsze założymy, że
klasyczny zbiór stanów X składa się z liczb całkowitych od 0 do n minus jeden dla pewnej dodatniej liczby całkowitej n, a możliwe
wyniki pomiaru to liczby całkowite od 0 do M minus jeden, znowu dla pewnej dodatniej liczby całkowitej M. Nie musi
istnieć żaden związek między liczbami n i M — obie są dowolnymi dodatnimi liczbami całkowitymi, i oczywiście moglibyśmy zastąpić
te zbiory dowolnymi klasycznymi zbiorami stanów, gdybyśmy tego chcieli. Przypomnijmy najpierw, jak działają pomiary rzutowe,
o których mówiliśmy po raz pierwszy w trzeciej lekcji serii. Przyjmując, że
wyniki pomiaru to liczby całkowite od 0 do n minus jeden, opisujemy pomiar rzutowy przez kolekcję
rzutów Pi 0 przez Pi M minus jeden, które sumują się do macierzy jednostkowej, a te macierze mają wiersze i
kolumny odpowiadające klasycznym stanom X, czyli innymi słowy, są to wszystkie macierze n na n.
Jeśli x jest w stanie kwantowym opisanym przez wektor stanu kwantowego s, to każdy możliwy wynik pomiaru
a pojawia się z prawdopodobieństwem równym kwadratowi normy euklidesowej Pi a pomnożonej
przez wektor s. Kwadrat normy euklidesowej dowolnego wektora jest równy iloczynowi skalarnemu tego
wektora z samym sobą, więc otrzymujemy wyrażenie widoczne na ekranie, i możemy je uprościć odrobinę,
korzystając z faktu, że Pi a jest rzutem, więc mnożenie go przez siebie nic nie
zmienia. Na koniec możemy przepisać uzyskane wyrażenie w nieco inny sposób, korzystając z własności cyklicznej
śladu, jak widać na ekranie, i jeśli nie jest oczywiste, dlaczego chcemy tak zapisać to wyrażenie,
WEBVTT
krótka odpowiedź jest taka, że chcemy zrozumieć, jak działają pomiary rzutowe dla macierzy
gęstości, i w szczególności przez liniowość mamy, że jeśli stan X jest opisany przez macierz gęstości rho, zamiast
wektora stanu kwantowego s, to prawdopodobieństwo pojawienia się wyniku a jest dane przez ślad rzutu
Pi a razy macierz gęstości rho. Musi tak być, bo jak widzieliśmy,
zawsze możemy myśleć o macierzy gęstości jako o ważonej średniej stanów czystych, i jeśli uśrednimy
odpowiednie prawdopodobieństwa, otrzymamy to wyrażenie, bo ślad jest funkcją liniową. To jest więc wyrażenie, na które
celujemy, i możemy je nieco uporządkować, skupiając się na macierzach
gęstości. Głównym celem tego zabiegu nawiasem mówiąc jest ustalenie punktu odniesienia do tego, czego już się nauczyliśmy
i zobaczenie, że ten opis pomiarów rzutowych jest w istocie szczególnym przypadkiem bardziej ogólnego opisu pomiarów, który
zaraz zobaczymy. To, co zrobię teraz, to zastąpię ten opis działania pomiarów rzutowych dla macierzy gęstości
opisem dla ogólnych pomiarów, żebyśmy mogli zrozumieć tę relację — i oto
ona. Ogólny pomiar, niekoniecznie rzutowy, jest opisany przez kolekcję dodatnio półokreślonych
macierzy P 0 przez PM minus jeden, które sumują się do macierzy jednostkowej, i jeśli ten pomiar jest wykonywany na X znajdującym się w
stanie opisanym przez macierz gęstości rho, to każdy wynik a pojawia się z prawdopodobieństwem równym śladowi PA *
rho. Krótko mówiąc, jedyna zmiana polega na tym, że rozluźniliśmy warunek na te macierze. W szczególności macierze
nie muszą być macierzami rzutowymi — muszą być jedynie dodatnio półokreślone, i odpowiednio zastąpiłem literę Pi literą P,
bo Pi to konwencjonalna nazwa rzutu, podczas gdy ja lubię używać litery P dla macierzy dodatnio półokreślonych.
To jest uogólnienie opisu, który mieliśmy dla pomiarów rzutowych, bo macierze rzutowe są zawsze dodatnio półokreślone
i w istocie można je alternatywnie definiować jako macierze dodatnio półokreślone, których wartości własne
mogą wynosić tylko zero i jeden. Możemy zauważyć, że ta definicja
ma sens, bo zawsze otrzymujemy wektor prawdopodobieństwa dla prawdopodobieństw wyników w następujący
sposób: po pierwsze, te liczby, które nazywam prawdopodobieństwami wyników, są zawsze nieujemnymi liczbami rzeczywistymi, bo
zarówno PA, jak i rho są dodatnio półokreślone, a ślad iloczynu dwóch macierzy dodatnio półokreślonych
jest zawsze nieujemną liczbą rzeczywistą — to zostawiam ci do przemyślenia.
Po drugie, liczby muszą sumować się do jedynki, bo ślad jest liniowy,
macierze P 0 przez PN minus jeden sumują się do macierzy jednostkowej, a macierze gęstości mają ślad równy
jeden, więc niezależnie od tego, od jakiej macierzy gęstości rho zaczęliśmy, prawdopodobieństwa wyników będą rzeczywiście zawsze tworzyć
wektor prawdopodobieństwa. Przyjrzyjmy się teraz kilku przykładom. Wspominałem już, że
pomiary rzutowe są szczególnym przypadkiem ogólnych pomiarów, bo rzuty są zawsze dodatnio półokreślone,
ale warto zacząć prosto, więc zacznijmy od pomiaru w bazie standardowej qubit. Możemy przedstawić pomiar w bazie standardowej
qubit przez dwie macierze P 0 i P1 zdefiniowane jak widać na ekranie. P 0 to ket zero bra zero, a P1 to ket jeden
bra jeden. Obie są macierzami dodatnio półokreślonymi, w rzeczy samej są rzutami, i wyraźnie sumują się do
macierzy jednostkowej, więc razem opisują pomiar. Jeśli zastosujemy ten pomiar do qubit
w stanie opisanym przez macierz gęstości rho, to prawdopodobieństwo pojawienia się wyniku zero to ślad P 0 * rho,
a prawdopodobieństwo wyniku jeden to ślad P1 * rho, i korzystając z własności cyklicznej śladu, otrzymujemy
dwa diagonalne wpisy rho, co się zgadza z oczekiwaniami. Oto kolejny przykład, gdzie tym razem
macierze nie są rzutami. Są jednak dodatnio półokreślone i przypadają się być macierzami gęstości,
ale to nie jest ważne. Ważne jest to, że sumują się do macierzy jednostkowej, więc razem opisują
pomiar. Możemy zobaczyć, co się dzieje, gdy ten pomiar jest wykonywany na qubit w stanie plus, na przykład żeby
zobaczyć, jak to działa dla jednego przykładu stanu, a obliczenie prawdopodobieństw jest pokazane na
ekranie. Zauważ w szczególności, że choć stan plus jest stanem czystym i możemy go reprezentować wektorem stanu kwantowego ket plus, to musimy
podstawić reprezentację macierzową tego stanu, czyli ket plus bra plus, do wzorów, żeby uzyskać
prawdopodobieństwa. Zaznaczę też, że ponieważ mówimy o destrukcyjnym pomiarze, nie ma żadnej
specyfikacji stanu kwantowego po pomiarze tego qubit, więc mamy tylko specyfikację
prawdopodobieństw wyników. Oto ostatni przykład na teraz i jest całkiem interesujący. To znowu pomiar jednego
qubit, i żeby go opisać, zacznijmy od zdefiniowania czterech wektorów stanu kwantowego znanych jako stany
tetraedryczne. Nazywają się stanami tetraedrycznymi, bo odpowiadają czterem wierzchołkom
regularnego czworościanu wpisanego w sferę Blocha. Żeby być precyzyjnym, gdy mówimy, że to jest regularny czworościan,
mamy na myśli czworoboczną bryłę, w której każda ze ścian jest trójkątem równobocznym, więc mamy tu doskonałą symetrię —
każda krawędź ma tę samą długość i między dowolnymi dwoma sąsiednimi
krawędziami tworzy się ten sam kąt. Teraz możemy zdefiniować interesujący pomiar z czterema możliwymi wynikami, jak widać na ekranie, czyli słowami możemy wziąć nasze
macierze jako reprezentacje macierzowe gęstości tych stanów podzielone przez dwa. Te są zdecydowanie dodatnio
półokreślone, bo są macierzami gęstości podzielonymi przez dwa, i można przeprowadzić arytmetykę, żeby sprawdzić,
że faktycznie sumują się do macierzy jednostkowej. Ale innym sposobem na to jest myślenie o symetrii — jeśli uśrednimy te cztery stany
razem, otrzymamy całkowicie zmieszany stan, który jest w centrum sfery Blocha, ale ponieważ dzielimy
każdy przez dwa zamiast przez cztery, otrzymujemy dwa razy całkowicie zmieszany stan, czyli macierz jednostkową. Nie powiem nic więcej o
tym pomiarze na razie, poza obserwacją, że nie jest on pomiarem rzutowym, ale jest dobrym przykładem i
zobaczymy go znowu później w lekcji. Innym sposobem opisywania ogólnych pomiarów jest jako kanałów, co teraz
omówimy. Idea polega na tym, że klasyczne stany probabilistyczne mogą być reprezentowane przez diagonalne macierze gęstości, więc
ponieważ wyniki pomiarów są klasyczne, możemy myśleć o pomiarach jako o kanałach, gdzie wyjście jest zawsze diagonalną macierzą gęstości
opisującą wynik pomiaru. Przyjrzyjmy się temu trochę bardziej szczegółowo. Jeśli myślimy
WEBVTT
abstrakcyjnie o ogólnym pomiarze, możemy opisać ten pomiar jako kanał fi. Układ wejściowy dla kanału to
jakikolwiek układ X, który jest mierzony, a układ wyjściowy to układ Y, którego klasyczne stany odpowiadają
wynikom pomiaru, które przyjmujemy jako liczby całkowite od 0 do n minus jeden dla pewnej dodatniej liczby całkowitej
M. Ponieważ wyniki pomiarów są klasyczne, wymagamy, żeby dla każdej wejściowej macierzy gęstości rho dla układu
X wyjście fi(rho) było diagonalną macierzą gęstości. Na przykład jeśli myślimy o
pomiarze w bazie standardowej qubit i myślimy o nim jako opisanym przez kanał, możemy go wyrazić jak mamy tutaj na ekranie.
Jeśli wejściowa macierz gęstości to rho, to otrzymamy wynik zero z prawdopodobieństwem równym bra 0 rho ket zero
i wynik jeden z prawdopodobieństwem bra jeden rho ket jeden, i jeśli wyrazimy te klasyczne
wyniki pomiaru jako macierze gęstości, otrzymamy to wyrażenie dla odpowiedniego kanału, i okazuje się,
że jest to nic innego jak całkowity kanał defazujący, co jest spójne z ideą, że całkowity kanał defazujący
reprezentuje ekstremalną formę dekoherencji, która może oznaczać różne rzeczy, ale gdy używam tego terminu, mam na myśli
tendencję stanów kwantowych do stawania się klasycznymi, bo środowisko wokół danego układu
w pewnym sensie obserwuje, czyli innymi słowy mierzy.
Wyniki pomiarów można więc opisywać jako kanały, jak właśnie opisałem, ale to nie jest tylko pewna możliwość — to
charakteryzacja ogólnych pomiarów. Mam przez to na myśli następujące: oczywiście istnieją kanały,
które nie reprezentują pomiarów, bo wyjście może nie zawsze być diagonalną macierzą gęstości. Ale jeśli
wyjście kanału jest zawsze diagonalną macierzą gęstości niezależnie od tego, jaki stan wejściowy rho wybierzemy, to koniecznie możliwe jest
wyrażenie tego kanału w formie pokazanej na ekranie dla pewnego wyboru pomiaru, czyli kolekcji
macierzy dodatnio półokreślonych sumujących się do macierzy jednostkowej. Jest to przyjemne z wielu powodów, w tym dlatego, że
w zasadzie mówi nam, że nasza definicja pomiarów jako kolekcji macierzy niczego nie
pomija. Innym sposobem powiedzenia tego jest to, że ten sposób myślenia o pomiarach jako kanałach jest operacyjny
lub może aksjomatyczny w tym sensie, że uchwytuje to, czym pomiar powinien być — czyli procesem fizycznym, który
przekształca informację kwantową w informację klasyczną, i okazuje się, że jest to całkowicie równoważne naszemu pierwszemu
opisowi pomiarów, który jest czysto algebraiczny. Nie będę przechodzić przez dowód równoważności w tym filmie, ale
nie jest to trudne, i jeśli jesteś zainteresowany(-a), możesz znaleźć dowód w materiałach pisemnych do lekcji, które są podlinkowane w opisie
wideo. Omówiliśmy, co się dzieje, gdy ogólny pomiar jest wykonywany na układzie w danym stanie,
przynajmniej w przypadku pomiarów destrukcyjnych. Następnie omówimy pomiary częściowe, czyli że tylko
jedna część układu złożonego jest mierzona. Żeby być precyzyjnym, załóżmy, że mamy parę układów XZ, które
razem są w stanie opisanym przez macierz gęstości rho, i pomiar opisany przez kolekcję macierzy dodatnio półokreślonych sumujących się do
macierzy jednostkowej jest wykonywany tylko na układzie X. Naturalnie prowadzi to do
wyniku pomiaru, i ponieważ mówimy o pomiarach destrukcyjnych, możemy sobie wyobrazić, że proces pomiaru niszczy układ
X, ale nadal mamy do czynienia z układem Z i musimy zrozumieć, jak pomiar X wpływa na
stan Z. Najpierw porozmawiajmy o prawdopodobieństwach wyników.
Ponieważ mówimy o pomiarze tylko układu X, prawdopodobieństwa pojawienia się różnych
wyników mogą zależeć tylko od stanu X w izolacji, czyli mogą zależeć tylko od
zredukowanego stanu X. W szczególności prawdopodobieństwo pojawienia się danego wyniku a jest dane przez
ten sam wzór co wcześniej, czyli ślad PA razy zredukowany stan X, który oznaczamy jako rho
indeks X. Stan rho indeks X jest uzyskiwany z rho przez wyśladowanie Z, więc możemy dokonać tego
podstawienia, i choć może nie być od razu oczywiste, wyrażenie, które otrzymujemy, można alternatywnie zapisać jak
pokazano na ekranie — to ślad PA tensorowany z macierzą jednostkową na układzie Z razy
rho. To jest równość, którą zdecydowanie warto poświęcić trochę czasu, żeby zweryfikować. Jest intuicyjna — nie robimy
niczego z Z, więc ma sens, że identyczność na Z powinna pojawić się w ten sposób, ale można to też zweryfikować
algebraicznie, i zostawiam to tobie wraz z sugestią, żebyś najpierw rozważył(-a) przypadek, gdy rho jest iloczynem tensorowym dwóch macierzy, a następnie
użył(-a) liniowości, żeby stwierdzić, że musi działać dla wszystkich rho. Powiem też, że nie zależy to od faktu, że PA
jest dodatnio półokreślone lub że rho jest macierzą gęstości — to jest równość, która działałaby dla dowolnego wyboru
macierzy w miejsce PA i rho, o ile mają odpowiednie wymiary dla wyrażenia,
żeby miało sens. Zobaczmy teraz, jak stan Z jest dotknięty przez pomiar — naturalnym podejściem
w moim odczuciu jest myślenie o pomiarze jako o kanale. Oto kanał, który kojarzymy z naszym pomiarem,
i myślimy o tym jako o kanale z układu X do nowego układu Y, którego klasyczne stany odpowiadają wynikom pomiaru, więc w tej formule
sigma reprezentuje stan tylko układu X. Jeśli zastosujemy ten kanał do
układu X, gdy para XZ jest w stanie rho, to otrzymamy macierz gęstości, którą mamy tutaj. Znowu
poświęć tyle czasu, ile potrzebujesz, żeby to zweryfikować, i znowu sugeruję, żebyś najpierw rozważył(-a) przypadek, gdy rho jest iloczynem tensorowym
dwóch macierzy, a następnie użył(-a) liniowości. Widzieliśmy ten typ stanu,
gdzie pierwszy układ jest klasyczny, a drugi kwantowy, jako przykład w lekcji
o macierzach gęstości. Każde a pojawia się z pewnym prawdopodobieństwem, które jest śladem drugiego czynnika tensorowego, więc możesz myśleć
o tych drugich czynnikach tensorowych jako o macierzach gęstości pomnożonych przez prawdopodobieństwa, więc żeby uzyskać stan
Z warunkowy na uzyskaniu danego wyniku pomiaru a, po prostu dzielimy przez prawdopodobieństwo, czyli innymi słowy
normalizujemy drugi czynnik tensorowy, dzieląc go przez własny ślad. Podsumowując, jeśli wykonamy
pomiar na X, gdy para XZ jest w stanie rho, to oto co się dzieje: po pierwsze, każdy wynik a pojawia się
z prawdopodobieństwem równym śladowi PA tensorowanego z identycznością razy rho, a po drugie, warunkowo na uzyskaniu
danego wyniku pomiaru a, stan Z jest dany przez wyrażenie pokazane na ekranie, które jest tym, co otrzymujemy
WEBVTT
przez normalizację macierzy, którą właśnie widzieliśmy chwilę temu, co jest tym samym co podzielenie macierzy przez prawdopodobieństwo
pojawienia się a. Powinienem wspomnieć, że ma to sens tylko wtedy, gdy prawdopodobieństwo jest niezerowe, bo w przeciwnym razie dzielimy
przez zero, ale to jest w porządku, bo nie musimy się przejmować rzeczami, które się nie zdarzają. W tej części
lekcji omówimy proste, ale fundamentalne twierdzenie o pomiarach, znane jako twierdzenie Neumark'a.
Krótko mówiąc, mówi ono, że każdy pomiar można zaimplementować tak, jak sugeruje rysunek na ekranie.
Mówiąc słowami, dany ogólny pomiar na układzie X można zaimplementować w następujący sposób:
najpierw wprowadzamy zainicjalizowany system workspace Y, którego klasyczne stany to możliwe wyniki pomiaru, które zakładamy, że są
ponumerowane od 0 do n minus jeden, następnie wykonywana jest operacja unitarna U na parze
YX, a potem wykonywany jest pomiar w bazie standardowej na Y. Więc wszystko jest w zasadzie ustalone,
poza wyborem U, i twierdzenie mówi, że faktycznie można wybrać tę operację unitarną
U tak, żeby prawdopodobieństwa dla różnych wyników zawsze zgadzały się z danym ogólnym
pomiarem. Zobaczmy teraz, jak udowodnić twierdzenie Neumark'a — nie jest to trudne. Musimy tylko dokonać dobrego wyboru dla
operacji unitarnej U i zweryfikować, że działa. Ale najpierw potrzebujemy podstawowego faktu
z teorii macierzy, mianowicie że dla każdej macierzy dodatnio półokreślonej P zawsze istnieje unikalna macierz dodatnio półokreślona
Q taka, że Q do kwadratu jest równe P. Ogólnie może istnieć wiele macierzy, które podniesione do kwadratu dają nam P, ale
zawsze jest tylko jedna z nich, która jest dodatnio półokreślona. Notacja używana do oznaczania tej macierzy to pierwiastek kwadratowy z
P i tak też się do niej odnosimy słownie. Jeśli chcesz obliczyć pierwiastek kwadratowy z P dla pewnej macierzy dodatnio półokreślonej
P, możesz to zrobić, najpierw obliczając rozkład spektralny P, a następnie
zastępując każdą z wartości własnych jej pierwiastkiem kwadratowym i zostawiając wektory własne bez zmian. Wartości własne są wszystkie nieujemne,
więc ma to sens, i jest dość łatwo zauważyć, że uzyskana macierz jest w istocie dodatnio półokreślona
i podniesiona do kwadratu daje P. Fakt, że jest unikalna, to inna kwestia — nie jest trudna do
udowodnienia przy użyciu podstawowych faktów o macierzach, ale jest niejako poboczna wobec lekcji, więc po prostu przyjmiemy tę część
jako daną. Teraz gdy mamy tę koncepcję, dość łatwo jest wyspecyfikować
operację unitarną U, która działa. Każda macierz unitarna pasująca do wzoru pokazanego na ekranie będzie
działać. Pierwsze n kolumn — zakładając, że X ma n klasycznych stanów jak poprzednio — są uzyskiwane przez ułożenie pierwiastków kwadratowych
macierzy opisujących pomiar jeden na drugim, a pozostałe kolumny mogą być jakie
chcemy — nie ma żadnej różnicy, o ile cała macierz jest unitarna.
Nawiasem mówiąc, jeśli zauważasz podobieństwo do związku między reprezentacjami Kraussa a Stein-spring kanałów, to nie jest to przypadkowe,
i w istocie to, co mamy tutaj, jest zasadniczo szczególnym przypadkiem tego, gdzie nasze macierze Kraussa są wszystkie dodatnio
półokreślone. Mamy więc dwie rzeczy do sprawdzenia: po pierwsze, że ten wybór U rzeczywiście działa, i po drugie
że można wybrać nieokreślone kolumny w sposób, który czyni U unitarną. Zacznijmy od pierwszej
rzeczy. Oto stan, od którego zaczynamy — dolny układ Y jest zainicjalizowany do stanu zerowego, podczas gdy górny układ
zaczyna w stanie rho, a następnie wykonujemy U, co oznacza, że sprzęgamy przez
U. Możemy to wszystko wyrazić w terminach macierzy blokowych jak pokazano na ekranie — mamy U po lewej, U†  po
prawej, a ket zero bra zero tensorowany z rho w środku, który przyjmuje formę, którą tu mamy, gdzie rho jest w
lewym górnym rogu, a wszędzie indziej są zera. Jeśli zastanowisz się przez chwilę nad tym iloczynem, jest oczywiste, że
nieokreślone wpisy U wcale nie mają znaczenia, bo zawsze są mnożone przez zerowe wpisy tej
macierzy w środku, i jeśli przeprowadzimy mnożenie, otrzymamy tę
macierz pokazaną tutaj, opisaną jako macierz blokowa, albo alternatywnie możemy wyrazić ją używając notacji bezpośredniej
w taki sposób, co w istocie jest dla nas wygodniejszą formą, więc skupmy się na tym
wyrażeniu. Dla wygody nadajmy tej macierzy, która jest macierzą gęstości, nazwę
sigma. Ostatnim krokiem jest pomiar w bazie standardowej na Y, więc obliczmy zredukowany stan w Y i
to jest łatwe mając wyrażenie, które mamy — po prostu wyśladzimy X, co odpowiada drugiemu czynnikowi tensorowemu.
Prawdopodobieństwo pojawienia się dowolnego danego wyniku a to diagonalny wpis odpowiadający a. Możemy to zapisać
tak, i jest to równe śladowi pierwiastka kwadratowego z PA razy rho razy pierwiastek kwadratowy
z PA, i korzystając z własności cyklicznej śladu otrzymujemy ślad PA razy rho,
co jest tym, na co liczyliśmy. Prawdopodobieństwa pojawienia się różnych wyników są więc poprawne — zawsze zgadzają się
z oryginalnym pomiarem, od którego zaczęliśmy. Drugą rzeczą do sprawdzenia
jest to, że można wypełnić nieokreślone kolumny U w taki sposób, żeby stała się
unitarna. Wynika to z faktu, że pierwsze n kolumn, czyli te tworzone przez pierwiastki kwadratowe macierzy opisujących
pomiar, są ortonormalne, co można sprawdzić dość bezpośrednio — odpowiednie szczegóły są tutaj
na ekranie, więc zatrzymaj wideo i poświęć chwilę na zastanowienie się nad tym, jeśli chcesz. Ale jak wcześniej sugerowałem,
jest to w rzeczywistości szczególny przypadek czegoś, z czym zetknęliśmy się w poprzedniej lekcji, i to
jest dowód. Dotychczas w lekcji skupialiśmy się na pomiarach destrukcyjnych, czyli takich, gdzie nie ma specyfikacji
stanu kwantowego po pomiarze mierzonego układu. W przypadku pomiaru niedestrukcyjnego natomiast
istnieje nie tylko klasyczny wynik pomiaru, ale też stan kwantowy po pomiarze mierzonego układu, i jak
zobaczymy, istnieje naturalne powiązanie z twierdzeniem Neumark'a. Istnieją różne sposoby formułowania pomiarów niedestrukcyjnych
w terminach matematycznych, ale zaczniemy od jednego sformułowania, które w zasadzie pochodzi bezpośrednio z twierdzenia Neumark'a.
Rozważmy ogólny pomiar, czyli destrukcyjny, opisany przez kolekcję macierzy dodatnio półokreślonych
P 0 przez PN minus jeden sumujących się do macierzy jednostkowej. Możemy następnie przekształcić ten
pomiar w pomiar niedestrukcyjny, po prostu rozważając implementację tego pomiaru, którą omówiliśmy w kontekście twierdzenia Neumark'a.
WEBVTT
Wprowadzamy nowy układ Y, wchodzimy z X przez operację unitarną U, a następnie wykonujemy pomiar w bazie standardowej
na Y. Układ X nadal tam jest i możemy rozważyć jego
stan, i na podstawie przeprowadzonej analizy możemy stwierdzić, że stan X po pomiarze, warunkowy
na uzyskaniu danego wyniku a, jest dany przez macierz gęstości, która wygląda
tak. Mówiąc słowami, sprzęgamy przez pierwiastek kwadratowy z odpowiedniej macierzy pomiarowej, a następnie
normalizujemy. Innym sposobem formułowania pomiarów niedestrukcyjnych, który jest bardziej ogólny, jest przez macierze Kraussa
kanałów, i jest to definicja pomiarów, którą znajdziesz w dobrze znanych podręcznikach, na przykład u Nielsena i
Changa. Załóżmy, że m0 przez m minus jeden to macierze kwadratowe spełniające
równanie pokazane na ekranie, czyli możemy myśleć o tych macierzach jako o macierzach Kraussa opisujących
kanał. W istocie macierze te opisują kanał, ale opisują też pomiar niedestrukcyjny.
Sposób działania, gdy układ w danym stanie rho jest mierzony, jest taki: po pierwsze, prawdopodobieństwa wyników są
dane przez równanie pokazane na ekranie — każdy wynik pojawia się z prawdopodobieństwem równym śladowi ma *
rho * ma†, a warunkowo na pojawieniu się wyniku a, stan mierzonego
układu wygląda tak. Pomiary niedestrukcyjne tego rodzaju można zaimplementować w sposób
podobny do tego, co mieliśmy w twierdzeniu Neumark'a, i zostawię to tobie do przemyślenia, jeśli
chcesz. Można uogólnić pojęcie pomiaru niedestrukcyjnego jeszcze dalej niż to, na przykład
istnieje pojęcie tzw. instrumentu kwantowego, które jest czasem całkiem przydatne, ale nie omówię tego w tym
filmie. W ostatniej części lekcji krótko omówię dwa zadania związane z pomiarami — rozróżnianie stanów kwantowych i tomografię stanów kwantowych.
Jest dużo do powiedzenia o obu tych pojęciach, i naprawdę tylko zarysujemy
powierzchnię, więc zacznijmy od wyjaśnienia, co te terminy oznaczają i jak się różnią.
Pierwsze to rozróżnianie stanów kwantowych. Idea polega na tym, że mamy znany zbiór stanów kwantowych
pewnego układu wraz z prawdopodobieństwami powiązanymi z tymi stanami. Żeby być precyzyjnym, załóżmy,
że rho 0 przez rho M minus jeden to macierze gęstości reprezentujące możliwe stany kwantowe układu X, a P 0
przez PN minus jeden to prawdopodobieństwa powiązane z tymi stanami. Jeśli zbierzemy prawdopodobieństwa w jeden
wektor, otrzymamy wektor prawdopodobieństwa. Zwięzłym sposobem powiedzenia tego jest, że mamy zespół stanów kwantowych.
Abstrakcyjnym sposobem myślenia o rozróżnianiu stanów kwantowych jako zadaniu lub problemie
jest to, że najpierw liczba między zero a N minus jeden jest wybierana losowo zgodnie z prawdopodobieństwami, układ X jest następnie
przygotowywany w stanie odpowiadającym losowo wybranemu numerowi, a celem jest ustalenie poprzez
pomiar X, która liczba została wybrana. Mamy więc skończoną liczbę
alternatyw wraz z pewnymi a priori i celem jest ustalenie, która alternatywa faktycznie nastąpiła. Dla niektórych wyborów stanów i
prawdopodobieństw może to być łatwe, a dla innych może nie być możliwe zrobienie tego bez pewnej szansy na popełnienie błędu.
Można zadać różne szczegółowe pytania, na przykład jakie jest minimalne prawdopodobieństwo popełnienia błędu
i jak wygląda pomiar osiągający to minimalne prawdopodobieństwo błędu. Tomografia stanów kwantowych natomiast
jest inna — tutaj mamy nieznany stan kwantowy układu, więc zazwyczaj
nie ma żadnych a priori ani żadnych informacji o możliwych alternatywach. Tym razem jednak nie jedna kopia stanu jest
dostępna, ale wiele niezależnych kopii jest dostępnych, czyli dla pewnej być może dużej liczby
n mamy n identycznych układów X1 przez Xn, z których każdy jest niezależnie przygotowany w stanie
rho. Tym razem celem jest znalezienie przybliżenia tego nieznanego stanu kwantowego jako macierzy gęstości poprzez mierzenie
układów. Podsumowując, w rozróżnianiu stanów kwantowych mamy jedną kopię
stanu i staramy się odróżnić spośród skończonej liczby znanych alternatyw, a w tomografii stanów kwantowych mamy wiele niezależnych
kopii nieznanego stanu kwantowego i celem jest znalezienie opisu tego stanu lub przynajmniej przyzwoitego przybliżenia.
Rozróżnianie stanów kwantowych jest interesujące, bo abstrakcyjnie ujmuje typ sytuacji, która często pojawia się
w obliczeniach i kryptografii, na przykład gdy jedna z skończonego zestawu możliwości nastąpiła i my lub ktoś inny stara się
dowiedzieć się, która to była, mierząc układ kwantowy. Najprostszy nietrywialny przypadek to
ten, gdy jest tylko dwoje Alternatyw, czyli m jest równe dwa, więc zadaniem jest rozróżnienie pary
stanów. Ten przypadek okazuje się być zasadniczo całkowicie rozwiązanym problemem, zakładając, że celem jest zminimalizowanie
szansy na niepoprawne rozróżnienie. Istnieje optymalny wybór pomiaru, który często jest nazywany
pomiarem Helstroma. Jest to pomiar rzutowy i może być opisany w następujący
sposób: najpierw rozważamy ważoną różnicę między dwiema alternatywami, czyli P 0 * rho 0 minus P1 * rho jeden.
Mnożymy prawdopodobieństwo losowania każdego z tych dwóch stanów przez same stany i bierzemy
różnicę. To jest macierz hermitowska, bo jest równa swojej sprzężonej transpozycji, więc ma rozkład spektralny
i wiemy w szczególności, że wartości własne są wszystkie liczbami rzeczywistymi. Załóżmy więc, że mamy
rozkład spektralny zapisany w formie pokazanej na ekranie. Następnie zbieramy
wartości własne w dwa zbiory, gdzie wszystkie dodatnie wartości własne są w jednym zbiorze, a wszystkie ujemne wartości własne są w
drugim. Żeby być precyzyjnym, przyjmijmy, że S0 to zbiór wszystkich indeksów k, dla których odpowiednia wartość własna Lambda K jest
nieujemna, a S1 to pozostałe indeksy, czyli te odpowiadające ujemnym wartościom
własnym. Tak naprawdę nie ma znaczenia, który zbiór zawiera indeksy odpowiadające zerowym wartościom własnym — dokonujemy tu
arbitralnego wyboru, by dołączyć je do S0, ale nie miałoby żadnego znaczenia, gdyby niektóre lub wszystkie z nich były dołączone do S1. Jedyne co naprawdę ma znaczenie to
że rozdzielamy dodatnie i ujemne wartości własne. Na koniec definiujemy dwa rzuty Pi
0 i Pi 1 jak pokazano na ekranie. Słowami, Pi 0 to rzut na
podprzestrzeń rozpiętą przez wektory własne odpowiadające nieujemnym wartościom własnym, a Pi 1 to rzut na przestrzeń
WEBVTT
rozpiętą przez wektory własne odpowiadające ujemnym wartościom własnym. To są rzeczywiście rzuty
i jeśli je dodamy, otrzymamy macierz jednostkową, bo wektory własne S 0 przez S N minus jeden tworzą
bazę ortonormalną. Jeśli ten pomiar jest wykonywany w rozważanej sytuacji, czyli
mierzony stan to rho 0 z prawdopodobieństwem P 0 i rho jeden z prawdopodobieństwem P1, to okazuje się,
że prawdopodobieństwo poprawnej identyfikacji ma dość prosty wzór w terminach wartości własnych Lambda 0 przez Lambda n minus
jeden. Nie będę przechodzić przez szczegóły obliczeń w tym filmie — możesz zajrzeć do materiałów pisemnych podlinkowanych w opisie wideo, jeśli jesteś
zainteresowany(-a), albo sprawdzić, czy możesz przekonać siebie, że ten wzór jest rzeczywiście poprawny. Możemy też wyrazić to
prawdopodobieństwo używając normy macierzowej powszechnie zwanej normą śladową. Jest to podobna notacja do normy euklidesowej dla wektorów,
z tym wyjątkiem, że mamy dolny indeks jeden, żeby wskazać, że to norma śladowa. Norma śladowa jest bardzo ważna i jest
bardzo często spotykana w obliczeniach kwantowych, ale nie powiem o niej za dużo w tej lekcji. Jednym ze sposobów
zdefiniowania jej dla macierzy hermitowskich jest to, że jest to suma wartości bezwzględnych wartości własnych, więc możesz myśleć
o tej drugiej równości jako wynikającej bezpośrednio z tej definicji. Norma śladowa może też być
definiowana w inne sposoby, które są bardziej ogólne, i spotkamy normę śladową ponownie w następnej lekcji. To w istocie
jest najlepsze, co możesz zrobić — ten pomiar jest optymalny, zakładając, że celem jest zmaksymalizowanie szansy poprawnego
odgadnięcia. Ten fakt jest czasem nazywany twierdzeniem Helstroma-Hołevo lub po prostu twierdzeniem Helstroma.
Nie możesz więc pobić tego pomiaru pod względem prawdopodobieństwa poprawności, i jest to przyjemne, bo
istnieje prosty przepis na sam pomiar i dokładny wzór na prawdopodobieństwo poprawności w terminach normy
śladowej. Norma śladowa jest często używana jako sposób mierzenia obserwowalnej różnicy między macierzami gęstości właśnie
z tego powodu, i gdy ludzie mówią o odległości śladowej między stanami, zazwyczaj mają na myśli
połowę normy śladowej różnicy między dwiema macierzami gęstości, co tutaj odpowiada przypadkowi, gdy P 0 i P1 wynoszą oba 1/2,
co jest naturalnym przypadkiem do rozważenia. Rozróżnianie stanów kwantowych dla dwóch stanów jest optymalnie rozwiązywane przez
pomiar Helstroma, dla którego mamy prosty przepis i prosty wzór na prawdopodobieństwo
poprawności. Więc co się dzieje, gdy chcemy rozróżniać trzy lub więcej stanów? W tym przypadku nie mamy
wzoru ogólnie dla optymalnego wyboru pomiaru ani prostego wyrażenia dla maksymalnego prawdopodobieństwa
poprawności. Możliwe jest jednak znalezienie dobrego przybliżenia optymalnego pomiaru z pomocą komputera,
i w szczególności można to zrobić używając naprawdę fascynującej i potężnej techniki optymalizacji zwanej programowaniem semidefinitycznym, ale nie jest to
coś, co można realnie zaimplementować ołówkiem i kartką papieru na przykład. Z drugiej strony, jeśli ktoś
da ci opis pomiaru i twierdzi, że ten pomiar jest optymalny dla zadania rozróżniania stanów kwantowych, to
w istocie bardzo łatwo jest zweryfikować lub obalić to twierdzenie, i można to zrobić używając tzw. warunków Hołevo-Yuen-
Kennedy-Lax. Nie będę wyjaśniać, czym są w tym filmie, ale są to proste warunki i jest całkiem fajne,
że jest to możliwe. Oto przykład, który nawiązuje do stanów tetraedrycznych,
które widzieliśmy wcześniej w lekcji. Załóżmy, że daje się nam jeden z tych czterech stanów, wybrany losowo
z prawdopodobieństwem jednej czwartej dla każdego, a naszym celem jest ustalenie, który stan nam dano. Być może nie jest to zaskakujące, ale
najlepszym wyborem pomiaru w tym celu jest pomiar tetraedryczny. Nie zawsze można zrobić
czegoś takiego dla dowolnej kolekcji stanów czystych, ale dzięki symetriom tu obecnym
to działa i faktycznie otrzymujemy prawidłowy pomiar, a przez warunki Hołevo-Yuen-Kennedy-Lax, które wspomniałem
kilka chwil temu, okazuje się, że jest całkiem proste do udowodnienia, że jest to rzeczywiście optymalny wybór
pomiaru. Konkretnie to, co tu się dzieje, jest takie, że pomiar jest zawsze poprawny z prawdopodobieństwem 1/2, co nie jest
złe, bo jest cztery alternatywy, więc prawdopodobieństwo poprawnego odgadnięcia jest dwa razy lepsze niż losowe zgadywanie, i to
jest najlepsze, co można zrobić dla tych stanów. Teraz powiem jeszcze trochę o tomografii stanów kwantowych,
gdzie mamy wiele niezależnych kopii nieznanego stanu kwantowego i celem jest znalezienie przybliżenia macierzy gęstości opisującej
ten stan. Istnieje kilka różnych wariantów tego problemu, które zależą od twoich założeń, i w
szczególności od tego, jakie rodzaje pomiarów dopuszczasz. Na przykład moglibyśmy żądać, żeby każdy układ był mierzony indywidualnie i
wyniki były jakoś łączone, żeby dojść do opisu macierzy gęstości, albo moglibyśmy pozwolić na to, żeby wszystkie
układy były mierzone razem jako jeden złożony układ, co jest znacznie lepsze w teorii, ale też znacznie bardziej
wymagające z technologicznego punktu widzenia. Oprócz wyborów dotyczących pomiarów istnieje też
ważna kwestia, jaką jest to, jak zrekonstruować opis macierzy gęstości z jakichkolwiek danych, które uzyskujesz
z pomiarów. Nie będę wchodzić w szczegóły — moim celem jest po prostu zasugerowanie,
że tomografia stanów kwantowych jest naprawdę bardziej pojęciem parasolowym mającym wiele różnych wariantów, niż
pojedynczą procedurą. Prowadzono wiele badań dotyczących tego problemu, w tym niektóre całkiem
niedawne przełomowe wyniki łączące liczbę kopii n z dokładnością przybliżenia, które można uzyskać, i nadal jest to
interesujący i aktywny obszar badań. Żeby zakończyć lekcję, przyjrzyjmy się tomografii stanów kwantowych
dla qubitów i jak możemy to zrobić. Załóżmy, że rho to macierz gęstości reprezentująca stan jednego
qubit, a X1 przez Xn to qubity, które wszystkie zostały niezależnie przygotowane w stanie rho, i dla
uproszczenia tej dyskusji załóżmy, że n jest duże. Możemy podzielić
układy na trzy mniej więcej równe stosy, i dla pierwszego stosu wykonamy pomiar względem bazy plus
minus. Dla każdego wyniku odpowiadającego plus będziemy punktować plus jeden, a dla każdego
wyniku odpowiadającego minus będziemy punktować minus jeden. Bardziej zwięzłym sposobem opisania tego pomiaru
jest to, że jest to pomiar Pauliego X, bo stany plus i minus są wektorami własnymi macierzy Pauliego X, a
odpowiednie wartości własne to plus jeden i minus jeden, i w istocie jest to też znacznie bardziej powszechny sposób opisu, i
WEBVTT
rzeczywiście oczekiwana wartość wyniku jest równa śladowi Sigma x * rho. Nie dowiadujemy się koniecznie, czym jest
ta wartość oczekiwana, ale jeśli uśrednimy wyniki, które uzyskujemy w wielu i wielu próbach, prawdopodobnie uzyskamy dobre
przybliżenie tej wartości oczekiwanej na mocy prawa wielkich liczb, a istnieją pewne dobrze znane ograniczenia statystyczne, które możemy na to nałożyć,
jeśli chcemy być bardziej ilościowi w tym twierdzeniu. Robimy coś podobnego z Sigma y na drugiej trzeciej części
układów. Jedyna zmiana polega na tym, że używamy stanów plus i i minus i, które są wektorami własnymi Sigma
Y, i podobnie dla Sigma Z, dla którego wektory bazy standardowej są wektorami
własnymi. Na koniec możemy użyć wzoru pokazanego na ekranie, który mówi nam, czym powinny być współczynniki,
jeśli rho jest zapisane jako liniowa kombinacja macierzy Pauliego, i podstawiając nasze przybliżenia tych współczynników
i ewentualnie korygując je trochę, żeby upewnić się, że otrzymamy macierz dodatnio półokreśloną, uzyskujemy przybliżenie
rho. Oczywiście są szczegóły, w które nie wchodziłem, takie jak dokładność przybliżenia i stopień
pewności, którą możemy mieć, ale miejmy nadzieję, że daje to podstawowe pojęcie o jednym ze sposobów, w jaki tomografia może być wykonywana na
qubicie. Możliwe jest też wykonanie tomografii qubit używając pomiaru tetraedrycznego, i w istocie okazuje się,
że jest to całkiem proste i eleganckie, przynajmniej w terminach matematycznych. Możemy wykonać po prostu
ten jeden pomiar na wszystkich niezależnych kopiach naszego nieznanego stanu kwantowego, i używając
niezwykłego wzoru pokazanego tu, możemy wymyślić przybliżenie naszego stanu, szacując ślad PK *
rho dla każdego K przez ułamek razy, gdy pojawia się odpowiedni wynik pomiaru. Ponownie działa to tylko dzięki
doskonałym symetriom, które mamy wśród tych czterech stanów, i w istocie są pewne naprawdę fascynujące nierozwiązane problemy, które odnoszą się do uogólnień
tego podejścia do większych układów, i to jest dobre miejsce, żeby zakończyć lekcję. Dziękuję za oglądanie i
mam nadzieję, że dołączysz do mnie na następnej lekcji, która jest o puryfikacjach i wierności. Do zobaczenia wkrótce.